haha the Joe Rogan experience you ever
take my Mitch Hedberg story which one I
did a skit with him
well when I was 26 someone a story yeah
man so me and Mitch I met at the Chicago
Comedy Festival and we clicked right and
we were walking around was living in
Chicago to town and we walked around he
was like you know I'm about to be rich
man deal or whatever in Montreal I
couldn't get much y'all to like look at
me but I he had just crushed in Montreal
he goes about to be rich man he pulls
out this velcro wives anko she see this
ring I live in Seattle
it's the pawn this ring so I could eat
and then I would go eat and get a gig
and then buy back I'm gonna have to do
that no more so he just sounds some big
deal so I needed a shirt for his HBO
half-hour special one when he's sitting
on the steps
mm-hmm and so I helped him pick out that
shirt and then I had a gig in Minnesota
I like after the first meeting I was can
I ride with you so we road trip to
Minnesota because he was from st. Paul I
spent a night in his in his home and
that's me I learned he was like a chef
and all that stuff it so we really
clicked bump into each other on the road
we were in Houston and uh he goes when I
decided I wanted to do comedy
I had asked it I'm taking it acid I got
my notebook and everything I saw I wrote
it I was it helped me funny like that so
I did a say rhythm and oh and we're both
in this hotel like the woman with it was
a woman who was a dealer you know she
came over and you know tell room and
that's when I learned what cartoons come
from like everything I saw was like a
[ __ ] cartoon and I was tripping man
and he videotaped me tripping and I'm
going
why is a a why is B B is the letter
Green good who said who said the
videotape me needs live he goes I'm that
clearly man we're going you should do
this on stage stay stay stay like I'm
like scatting man right go and I'm
seeing on sing and then like
I started I was on his whole thing like
all I kept thinking about was [ __ ]
right and I saw and I was dating this
girl and this is not me use a calling
card it was my my mom's number in hers
and I was afraid that I've called in the
girl as I was talking to her on the
phone and I was on the bed are you high
you know just [ __ ] up the whole thing
and I go yeah don't don't do anything
don't jump I was like why are you
putting that [ __ ] in my head like cuz
whatever she saw I could see like I
could physically see it and then I look
over in the bed next to me in Mitch's
like [ __ ] the girl that bought the
you know like oh [ __ ] I'm in the orgy
but not really like and then like my
body started shaking and the whole [ __ ]
like left my my body so that's how like
you know that was my experience I never
did it again never desire to do it again
but I did it with Mitch and it was like
it was like this crazy thing
[Applause]